[Musique]
depuis qu'elle est mère de famille la
nutritionniste jessica langlois a
complètement transformé sa façon de
préparer les repas tu me rendais compte
que j'ai essayé un petit peu de on peut
faire comme tout le monde planifiées à
l'avancé
qu'est ce qu'on va manger lundi qu'est
ce qu'on va manger mardi puis d'être
super organisée puis ça marchait pas
soit si je le faisais je gaspillais des
choses où j'arrivais tout simplement
pour l'autre c'est plutôt tout au niveau
de la protéine c'est ce qui ce gaz peut
facilement fait que je trouvais comme
des façons de cuisiner les ingrédients
puis de les entreposer au congélateur
pour doubler soir où j'ai rien prévu
mais au moins je peux me débrouiller
sans son congélateur est devenu son
complice tutti protéines fruits légumes
et les incontournables oignons se cuit
ou cru 5 rue aux quais ouest les congèle
cru donc fait des fois on a tendance à
atik passé tout droit puis on lit mais
pas parce qu'il faut sortir la planche
le couteau en coop lannion si on enlève
cette étape là déjà
ben c'est le fun on a déjà un beau
raccourci tu fais moi j'ai juste à
sortir mon sac je prends une poignée
puis je l'amène en point
[Musique]
poulet boeuf haché d'être comme ça c'est
huit véhicules
oui les protéines la viande cela fait
toujours courir comme ça
encore une fois j'ai juste apprendre ce
que j'ai besoin parce que l'idée c'est
que ce soit vraiment en vrac dans le sac
donc c'est pas une congélation qui est
comme tout en bloc
j'ai pas besoin de faire décongeler un
plat au conflit donc on peut l'utiliser
pu naître directement dans la poêle puis
ça notre cet atelier super express en
librairie vous trouverez de nombreux
ouvrages sur ce qu'on appelle en anglais
le batch cooking on prétend préparer les
plats pour une semaine complète en moins
de deux heures jessica a plutôt opté
dans son livre pour le foot prep où la
préparation d'un grand diable
la technique est simple on coupe des
ingrédients que l'on cuit ou pas et que
l'on congèle sur une plaque à biscuits
le foot prep mois la méthode que je
préconise le plus c'est de faire des
ingrédients j'aime bien cuisiner par
étapes fac et là je fais une étape en
premier j'aurais cuisiner certains
ingrédients l'entreprise soit le
résultat je veux même pas les
assaisonner tu as maintenant je veux
faire des du poulet ce sera pas du
poulet citron romarin ou peu importe je
reçois après juste un bon poulet nature
puis après ça vexe pullella ben on peut
le faire pour les terriens qui on peut
faire un développeur poulet boeuf ou
autre
l'important c'est le cuisiner des
ingrédients qui peuvent se décliner en
multiples plats chili tacos au boeuf et
autres alors on a ici les ingrédients
nécessaires pour faire un macaroni si
noir vous avez donc sorti du congélateur
des oignons du champignon dépouillement
et bien sûr la protéine oui le match
exactement les pas sont pas prêts culte
pourquoi celle là je les ai pas faites
précuire parce que je mets tout dans la
même casserole fait que je sais que tous
carmen
pour accueillir en même temps combien de
temps à peu près la cuisson quelque
chose comme ça mon but c'est d'avoir une
longueur d'avancé
donc j'ai déjà une étape de fait comme
on restera l'autre but c'est je peux
économiser aussi parce que quand les
produits sont en jambes et à l'épicerie
c'est là que je peux en acheter plus
puis le genre magazine je fais mes
réserves puis je peux aussi profiter des
produits de saison donc quand et elle
attend des courgettes des bleus et les
oranges à l'hiver bello c'est là que je
fais ma réserve aussi avoir des réserves
de petits fruits permet à toute la
famille de se préparer des collations
nutritives à longueur d'année pour une
fraction du prix
ça oblige de prévoir longtemps davance
l'époque on va manger ou pas du tout
aller vers les verts c'est que on peut
décider justement la dernière minute
parce que j'ai toujours quelque chose
que je peux transformer puis faire un
repos avec si je vais à l'épicerie belge
à prévoir mais deux trois premières
journées de la semaine plus souvent
jeudi vendredi
je le sais plus et j'ai fais idée ben là
je vais aller piger dans les réserves
catégorie lunch et des enfants ou nos
trois plages
on est partis avec des pâtes cuites les
tortues guionie j'aime bien ça les
congeler puis ce sera fort des lunch et
décongèle pendant la nuit encaisser ça
on fait la veille et on place au frigo
et ça va décourager tout doucement
jusqu'au lendemain exactement
gt5 avant d'être les parts dans le le
plus à l'aise
ça me prend le temps d'enlever sa fête
de la petite grappe si on peut dire je
rajoute rien lunch d'enfants primaire
maintenant je reprends la moitié même
chose avec conduit pois congelés elles
ont aussi monde et congelés pendant la
nuit
c'est doux c'est ça est fini
pour dessert on ajoute un peu du bourg
et des petits fruits congelés donc c'est
comme si ton frigo était rempli de tout
ce qui m'est que tu a planifié le oui
mais c'est ça c'est organisé mais dans
le but d' improviser sans forcer une
façon de s'organiser pour improviser
plein de recettes avec soin comme ça on
n'est jamais vraiment pris au dépourvu
[Musique]